foreign
George listen to this I'm scared you
should be scared for all of all of us
parents file a lawsuit this is an
article from foxbusiness.com
parents file lawsuit saying their kids
are addicted to fortnite
for those of you who don't know fortnite
is a video game
a video game
lawsuit's been filed in Canada by
parents who say their kids are addicted
to the video game fortnite they say that
their kids are so addicted they don't
take care of regular everyday hygiene
such as showering
some kids are so dependent on fortnite
they've stopped eating and sleeping
according to BBC News and reported by
Insider
the court concludes this is a serious
issue to be argued supported by
sufficient and specific allegations as
to the existence of risks or even
dangers arising from the use of
fortnight
they're equating the the in the suit
they're equating this to the the makers
of the game to Tobacco manufacturers
right so you could replace fortnite with
cigarettes and read that article that
does it that's right so here's my
thought
um
there's a lot of crazy in this
push back if if I'm out of bounds here
okay
um there's no secret I'm pretty open
about my disdain for video games
um I would rather instead of my kids
playing baseball on a video game I'd
rather them go outside and play baseball
with people that makes sense or maybe
just weather and a ball and like a stick
whatever
so I'm not a huge fan of video games I
also understand that they're fun and
there's some data saying that they're a
way for people to engage in Partridge
blah blah sure
where I struggle here is
you're the parents
you're the parents but it's more fun to
blame someone else John you're the
parents if your child is addicted to a
video game
smash the video game controller and
throw it in the fireplace rip all the
cords out but then they're gonna be mad
at me as the parent John that
wow that is called parenting that is
called setting boundaries
it cut the cut the internet off but then
I can't look at my cut the internet off
do whatever you have to do if somebody
you love who is a dependent on your care
is an addict and unable to get these
services on their own but they'll just
do it on their phone smash their phones
get rid of all you're the parent the
cool thing about all these electronic
systems is they've got this uh and I
didn't know this until recently on the
side of them there's a button and it has
the letters o f f and you can just push
it and the whole thing I've never tried
that that's amazing what a life hack
turn it off turn it off turn it off this
is different than
being told I think being told hey uh
cigarettes
are in fact they're not addictive at all
um they're not great for you right but
they do calm you down they do make you
feel a little better or whatever and
then they're being troves of data hiding
this
um we can't let anybody knows that hey
this is actually killing everybody
um it's different
then parents simply unable to say sorry
this is over and if this is a true true
addiction they need to get your kids the
mental health care that they need after
you've done the thing that a parent
should do which is Take Your Kids out of
danger
which in this case means using the off
button because you're the parents my
okay so am I am I crazy no I'm just
picturing what would happen if a parent
went and just turned the TV off while
the kids playing fortnite and the kid
just explodes in Rage
I just I want to be in the room for that
because it's entertaining to me
personally because I remember that as a
kid you know the parent comes on and
turns off the TV and you're playing the
video game it's like game on I mean you
go full adrenaline rage mode as the kid
well here's what one of the one of the
comp one of the company spokes people
said parents can receive playtime
reports that track the amount of time
their child plays each week and require
parental permission before purchases are
made and so the company stopped short of
saying hey you can turn the game off and
not let your kid play because they don't
want to do that that's enough because
they want to sell the game
but built into the game is this idea
that hey parents you will send you a
report of how much your kid is on right
maybe you're working three jobs
um you don't have to you're you're not
at home a lot we'll help you out
nah I don't want to look at that or or
hey we can go ahead and we'll give you a
specific passcode just for you parents
so your kids can't get on and buy a
bunch of stuff that makes sense nah
let's just uh I'm suing you but this is
equivalent John I I mean you devoured a
pack of gummies earlier and you love a
gummy bear it's like you suing Haribo
gummies for being like I'm addicted to
your gummy bears and it's your fault hey
I want Millions I actually covered this
on my show
I think there's something to that
um I think there are there are addictive
elements to prepackaged foods and I
think that given enough time that data
will emerge it's there we know people
are addicted to sugar and Humanity
and
I got a choice to make I looked at those
gummy bears on the way in and thought
I'm gonna future John is gonna feel not
that great but right now John is going
to feel awesome and I nailed him and you
even looked at me and said oh I'm your
accountability partner I thought we
weren't doing even my wife will
occasionally put her hand on my arm and
be like
just think about tomorrow John just
think about tomorrow right and I I but I
have a choice because I'm an adult I'm
not going to sue them for tricking me
it's a bag of Gummy snacks [ __ ] out of
the gate going all just that's not
probably wise but this parents
at some point
either
it's and this is me being completely
serious at some point if you look at the
data on the Mental Health crisis we have
in our country with kids
I am convinced beyond a shadow of a
doubt that the quote-unquote Mental
Health crisis is simply the bodies of
our children responding to they've been
let left completely alone they're
isolated they're not a part of their
families because Mom and Dad are super
busy and super stressed out and super
raged out and super stuck on the news
and they're sitting there swiping on
their own phones and these kids are
completely alone and they're locked in
these schools and they're
we've created this system for these kids
to exist and fortnite is their only way
out and
as parents at some point
either their bodies are going to revolt
or we are going to have to step up and
be actual parents which means saying no
and making a 14 year old mad at you or
turning the Box off or throwing it out
the Second Story window whatever you got
to do to keep your kids safe
stop blaming and start parenting yeah we
can't Outsource this to technology which
is kind of what's happened at this point
digital babysitters man yeah and I mean
I was part of the generation that grew
up we played video games but we also
went outside and still did stuff and my
parents loved me and I you know they
didn't have super strict you gotta but
they just raised me in such a way to go
hey maybe don't spend your entire day
glued to a screen either right that
can't be good for you I don't know that
we need studies to even prove that it's
a sad like study show it's like uh I
think I think you and I had this
conversation
um I was a part of a of a brain science
study a lot of questionnaires and yeah
yeah and they brought us in and gave us
like the six or seven or five things
whatever and I remember my grandmother
had literally told me six out of the
seven or seven I mean it was like go
outside spend time with people turn off
this Electronics it was like oh this
this is neuroscience I thought this like
literally my grandmother told me that
and so anyway a lot of common ground
between common sense and Neuroscience
yes and hey I might let my kids play
video games this upcoming year I've
thought about it that's big right
it will be for a very very limited time
with supervision will you play with them
I feel like that's a key maybe I might I
might be more fun but I'm not going to
cash in my parental responsibilities
just because they're holding a
controller in their transfix on a screen
I'm still there dad whether they're
holding a video game controller or not